1 les 10 conseils déjà du docteur Jimmy
Mohamed pour être bien dans son corps tu
mets good
surtout ne pas faire de régime drastique
alors c'est bientôt l'été il faut pas
faire non plus tout et n'importe quoi
c'est à dire ne plus rien manger et se
retrouver comme un concept cet été
complètement on va voir fleurir dans les
magazines sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
les dans les articles des régimes pour
être prêts pour l'été c'est souvent ça
moi j'ai envie de dire aux gens ne soyez
pas prêts pour l'été mais pour le
restant de votre vie et bien n'ayez pas
comme objectif de rentrer dans un
maillot de bain d'être sur la plage ça
on s'en fiche évidemment si vous sentez
bien moi j'ai aucun problème mais de se
dire que le poids que j'ai aujourd'hui
et bien peut-être que je vais améliorer
les choses sur des mois ou des années
mais absolument pas courir assez régimes
qui vont marcher sur l'instant vous
allez perdre vos trois quatre cinq kilos
mais dès lors qu'on va reprendre une
habitude alimentaire normale on va tout
reprendre et on va être frustré et on va
recommencer et c'est l'effet yoyo donc
l'idée c'est de se dire on enlève cette
pression qui est un peu mise notamment
dans les magazines et on essaie de
manger différemment pour manger mieux et
investir sur le long terme en réalité on
parle beaucoup du
jeûne intermittent
[Rires]
il y a des gens qui confondent régime
plastique et jeunes intermittents alors
ces deux méthodes complémentaires qui
sont différentes évidemment que le jeûne
intermittent ça a des vertus en réalité
il faut bien comprendre une façon
générale que toute notre journée tourne
autour de l'alimentation le matin
qu'est-ce que je vais prendre au petit
déjeuner le midi qu'est-ce que je vais
déjeuner l'après midi au goûter
qu'est-ce que je vais prendre le dîner
qu'est-ce que je vais manger et en
réalité on a un rapport un peu
pathologique à la nourriture et lorsque
vous faites du jeûne intermittent et
bien vous distinguez la fin de l'envie
de manger moi je fais du jeune
intermittent c'est à dire que je ne
prends pas de petit déjeuner le matin on
rappelle que jeûne intermittent c'est de
ne pas manger sur une plage horaire donc
durant une période de la journée ou de
la nuit on ne mange pas donc on saute le
petit déjeuner on fait du jeûne
intermittent c'est pour être efficace
c'est 16h à partir de 16h on est
efficace à partir de 16h on est efficace
moi tu vois voilà j'ai fait un jeune
intermittent et on peut le faire deux
fois par semaine on n'est pas obligé de
faire tous les jours et on va se rendre
compte qu'au bout de quelques jours ça
améliore les paramètres métaboliques
donc c'est des vertus pour la santé et
ça permet de perdre du poids de façon
complémentaire un rééquilibrage
évidemment que si vous faites du jeûne
et que le soir vous mangez un peu tout
et n'importe quoi bah vous perdez tous
les bénéfices mais oui le jeune
intermittent et intéressant pour perdre
du poids il faut faire attention au
sucre caché complètement il faut faire
extrêmement chaud c'est-à-dire il se
cache où dans la maison alors il faut
pas bannir le sucre d'une façon générale
c'est vrai qu'on dit le diabolisme le
truc le sucre que vous allez manger dans
une pomme pose pas de problème parce
qu'il est entouré de fibres et du coup
l'absorption du sucre va être différent
mais on donne un exemple tout simple ce
genre de canette que les jeunes
consomment assez régulièrement boisson
énergisante qui soit disant donne de
l'énergie en réalité dedans quand on
regarde la composition il y a pas grand
chose il y a l'équivalent d'un café bon
ça fait pas grand chose un peu de
taurine qui va améliorer l'effet de la
café la taurine c'est ce qu'on appelle
un acide aminé on a des protéines ces
protéines sont composées d'acides aminés
c'est les petits colliers qui vont
composer une perle qui est la protéine
la taurine c'est un acide aminé qui va
stabiliser un peu la caféine donc quand
vous prenez ce genre de boisson et ben
la caféine va agir un peu plus longtemps
puisque normalement quand vous prenez un
café du matin vous avez un shoot très
rapide et puis il y a une descente au
bout deux ou trois heures on a envie de
reprendre un café cette taurine elle a
ses fesses stabilisant mais en réalité
les faits shoutes que vous allez avoir
c'est le sucre parce que dans une
canette comme ça il y a 473 millilitres
vous avez 48 g de sucre
alors on va revenir sur le Light après
48 g de sucre c'est ça c'est 9 morceaux
de sucre
que vous allez voir sans vous rendre
compte incroyable mais regardez ça c'est
hyper intéressant un deux trois quatre
cinq six septune en fait mais on peut le
voir l'effet que ça donne
dans le corps quoi et ça c'est ça c'est
l'équival ça c'est le sucre dans ce
genre de boisson
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça c'est
formidable non mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça mais c'est pour prendre
conscience quoi qu'en réalité c'est du
sucre c'est c'est du sucre tout
simplement 48 g de sucre dans une canne
et c'est la même chose avec le cola
toutes les boissons sucrées qui
contiennent 10 g de sucre pour 100 ml et
Mathieu parlait tout à l'heure des light
alors là dedans
alors oui très bien mais on rajoute de
façon artificielle des choses qu'on peut
retrouver dans l'alimentation non mais
c'est vrai pour faire très simple
là-dedans il y a de la carnitine aussi
oui très bien on trouve dans les
protéines dans la viande ah bah c'est ça
donc là de la viande là-dedans non il y
a pas de la viande dedans
mais en plus de ça c'est sucré mais ils
ont rajouté du sucre à l'OSE qui est un
édulcorant c'est un faux sucre c'est un
faux sucre et ce faux sucre une étude
une serre montre en 2022 que sa favorise
les maladies cardiovasculaires et
certains cancers lorsqu'on en consomme
trop allez bah en fait il faut bien
comprendre que ce qu'on boit ou ce qu'on
mange à une influence majeure sur notre
santé d'une façon générale et en réalité
l'accès de l'énergie qu'on va avoir et
bien c'est l'accès de sucre mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand vous prenez
ça et ben vous avez un organe qui
s'appelle le pancréas qui se retrouve
juste ici qu'est-ce qui va faire vous
avez beaucoup de sucre il va faire une
un shoot d'insuline tout d'un coup votre
taux de sucre va baisser et vous allez
être fatigué c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on
consomme trop de sucre on est fatigué on
n'est pas en forme typiquement le matin
le petit déjeuner sucré n'est pas adapté
si vous voulez vous réveiller le matin
consommer des protéines les protéines
vont réveiller le sucre va endormie des
œufs brouillés je peux vous donner le
prix de tous ces produits non sérieux ça
va au juste prix une casse pas les
couilles
je peux vous dire que la canette noire
elle vaut 1,30 €. et la boisson
énergisante 2,22 et on peut faire un
complément avec ça les boss 0,70
centimes
le téléphone en ordre et lui c'est un je
vous ai dit qu'on aspiré le prix de tous
les produits de France et qu'on peut
retrouver facilement sauf que là vous
dites que par exemple ça c'est 80
centimes il y a 75 g la version à 100 g
elle coûte un peu plus cher entre 1 euro
et 1,20 € plus
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ça la question
c'est pas cher on paye ça 1,20 on se dit
mais c'est pas très cher mais il y a 100
g mais au kilo ça fait 12 euros le kilo
en réalité on est sur le prix de la
viande ou certains poissons alors qu'on
a consommé ça et on se dit mais c'est
pas très cher donc j'aimerais faire
comprendre aux gens que la malbouffe
elle coûte très cher et on dit en ce
moment dans un contexte d'inflation il
est difficile de se bien se nourrir et
c'est factuel mais encore plus quand on
prend des produits ultra transformés si
on revient à des produits bruts simples
comme de la pomme de terre ça paraît
tout bête on va souvent critiquer les
frites ce qui pose problème dans les
frites c'est la cuisson dans de l'huile
mais pas la cuisson au four ou à la
poêle c'est des aliments qui coûtent pas
cher qui font pas forcément grossir
alors que ça ça fait grossir ça coûte
très cher et c'est pas bon pour la santé
alors justement il va parler du mauvais
sucre on va parler de la patate à
tartiner alors ça moi je suis en ouf de
la pâte à tartiner j'en mets même sur le
corps
vous savez que les mecs font de fait que
dans les concours de musique
bodybuilding ils mettent du nutella sur
eux moi j'en avais pas j'ai j'ai j'ai
mis d'après
non mais franchement ça c'est ça parce
que ça il y a ils ont jamais réussi à
faire le même goût genre copier comment
ça se fait alors déjà ça il faut bien
comprendre que quand on a 100 g de pâte
à tartiner de ce type on a plus de 50 g
de sucre non donc en fait dans 100 g
vous avez encore une fois tout ça de
sucre chaque cuillère que vous prenez
qui fait 15 g pour en mettre sur une
tartine c'est quasiment neuf g de sucre
c'est à dire un morceau de sucre et demi
à
15 g c'est 8,4 g de sucre une cuillère
non un peu plus quand même c'est 15 g
c'est une cuillère à soupe qu'on va
mettre sur une tartine qu'on va étaler à
chaque fois vous mangez un morceau de
sucre et demi et le problème c'est que
les gens vont se tourner vers des choses
bio en se disant c'est bio donc c'est
mieux alors la seule différence qu'on
peut avoir entre les deux c'est que
dedans vous avez de l'huile de palme
dans la pâte à tarte Disney que tout le
monde connaît qui est une huile bas de
gamme de mauvaise qualité qui favorise
les maladies cardiovasculaires chose que
vous n'avez pas dans c'est à dire qu'on
mange tout le plateau l'enfant
quelque chose que j'entends
régulièrement les gens me disent peu
importe ce que je mange je ne prends pas
de poids et certains sont très fiers de
dire quelle bande de connards
mais il faut bien que ce n'est pas parce
que vous me prenez pas de poids que vous
n'avez pas des artères malades bien sûr
que vos organes ne sont pas en train de
partir
je vais faire un électro parce que genre
je devais faire un truc de un gros truc
de sport et donc on devait faire un
écrou écoute-moi bien je fais d'électro
et j'envoie l'électro à mon père qui est
notamment
cardiologue généraliste urologue
c'est vrai je lui envoie mon père me dit
c'est ton électro ça il me dit tu viens
tout de suite
non il faut que tu viennes tout de suite
il me dit j'arrive il me dit un gars qui
a un électro comme ça il fait pas trois
pas dans la rue non donc immo en fait et
en fait ils se sont trompés ils m'ont
donné l'électro de quelqu'un d'autre
imagine alors tu imagines quand je suis
en voiture moi en plus je suis un ouf je
suis comme ça dans la voiture je crois
que je vais mourir 15 fois
et mon père me rassure en me disant
écoute je vais te dire la vérité je te
trouve je te sens pas très fatigué je te
sens pas trop essoufflé tout ça parce
que il me dit l'électro que tu m'as
envoyé le gars il fait trois pas dans la
rue il m'a dit c'est direct
l'hospitalise direct ça arrive ça des
fois ou pas
voilà non non mais j'ai essayé de sauver
le gars quand même j'ai appelé tout ça
j'ai dit voilà c'est bien ça bien sûr
oui parce que là les gars
mais c'est vrai et si vous allez mourir
mais il y a quand même un gars en
dangereux je dis frère rentre tu vas
mourir
va voir mon père il est urologue face à
cheval tout va bien tu vois le bonhomme
là je vais te dans le cul
avec les canettes avec les canettes
alors vas-y est-ce qu'une chose que tu
médites donc en fait le point de se
résume pas la bonne santé ne se résume
pas au poids que vous faites et on va
dire mais du coup bon on a pas le droit
de prendre ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut
prendre le matin et bien des
alternatives qui coûtent pas forcément
plus cher et donc plutôt que de prendre
de la pâte à tartiner prenez par exemple
du beurre de cacahuète en terme de goût
effectivement ça n'a rien à voir mais
c'est ça
et gentil alors pour manger de la viande
mais à la place de la viande puisque
vous avez et bah vous prenez du fromage
frais le goût n'est pas c'est pas le
même dose quoi tu vois c'est bien qu'on
vous adorez les pâtes et ben si vous
aimez les pages si vous n'avez pas de
pâte vous mangez du merlot le problème
c'est que les industriels ont réussi à
nous mettre dans la tête que ce genre de
produit c'est adapté et que comme le
packaging est sympa comme on bout en
bout en bout on bouge pas bon c'est bon
comme il y a du marketing et bien on
associe ça on donne ça aux enfants très
bon du plaisir parce que oui c'est bon
mais en fait c'est de la chimie en
réalité tout ce qu'on vous montre là
c'est pas vraiment de la cuisine c'est
des produits ultra transformés et quand
on réfléchit et qu'on se dit qu'est-ce
que je peux faire de différent et ben
effectivement c'est pas tout à fait
pareil mais dans le beurre de cacahuète
vous avez quatre fois moins de
cacahuètes mais il y a 400 mètres il y a
un peu plus de gras mais il y a des
protéines avec ça et donc plutôt prends
que de prendre une tartine avec ça et
ben prenez du beurre de cacahuète vous
aurez moins de sucre et vous aurez des
protéines donc quitte à choisir quelque
chose